all right man bootleg cat podcast all
the way in the Bay Area
I came out here to [__] with my guy
burner man special edition special
edition at your first of all this new
compound you have
it is a
man I wish well listen we're gonna do a
tour on the YouTube channel so people
will be able to see it but man this [__]
is crazy dog like this is some real like
uh as you would like to say some real
Mafia [__] it's like ghost [__] dog like
[__] we built everything you've seen
today from the house on the couch in the
front room pacing in the house and so
you know landlords could be a pain in
the ass so I I wanted to wait to build
something like this until I was a
landlord until I could buy the building
and kind of decide what I want to do I
want to do it you know and just not have
to answer anyone I've seen a lot of big
businesses even in this area being
pushed out by their landlord yeah and
that [__] I would never do that ever I
was gonna say like you've always had
like you know you're always Diversified
to say the very least right but in terms
of like the content space you've always
you know I think back to the days where
you were like going viral on a world
star you know what I'm saying like for
Wild Things
all the way to now we're like you know
you've had a show like borders
Roundtable that was dope I I don't know
if you're bringing that back or not are
you planning on bringing them back yeah
you know like podcast for me is like a
little tough like it's just like um it's
kind of like you have to be really
consistent and you've been super
consistent so I give you props on that
but for me it's like
I think the cookings where the Hearts at
not for sure like and I really like a
lot of people like yo he's just doing a
cooking show and I see a lot of people
doing cooking shows and doing cooking
content but I grew up in the kitchen my
father had a restaurant growing up you
know that and there's a beast of a cook
he's a good cook and then um but I feel
like
besides the cooking show I think that
like we want to build like the urban
Food Network and that's what I'm trying
to do over here that's why you see this
building completely empty
um the warehouse you saw is completely
empty I'm trying to get some Capital
some serious Partners I understand the
vision
to kind of create like what we like to
watch on the Food Network I mean the
Food Network is dope I you we all get
stuck watching it for hours but it's
repetitive it's the same chefs Guy Fieri
shout out to him and it's for certain
like crowd it's a certain crowd but like
there's a whole world out there of like
viral Instagram chefs killing it there's
a whole world of like you know just the
black and brown Community doing their
thing and just in the food world it's
just it's being ignored by the
mainstream television so our goal is to
to build a networking so I said just
like podcasting is cool but
I'm in the bay one not many people rode
through here and two I don't really know
if I want to share this place with that
many people I kind of want to keep it
yeah if you have too many people coming
in and out like you said like this is a
special place it's it's pure right now
right you know I got to keep a little a
yada and I mean on my hip but that's
good with me like I don't want to have
full security now and not be able to
sleep but I like it the way it is now
and I think food content is pretty pure
yeah I was gonna say with the food [__]
so the goal in this like really is like
to eventually try to have a channel
that's on TV yeah you know
either like a channel on TV or like
building my own network that consists of
like a food segment of things like a
like a true crime series kind of you
know style content short films that we
debut I really want to build my own
network really yeah and I got some good
things going on
um we spoke about I don't know the last
time I have a scripted series and it
works a really big Network
and it's a big budget and I think it's
going to do really well and I feel like
while I'm in those doors you know me I'm
a wiggle I'm gonna get to know people
I'm gonna be able to shake hands rub
shoulders with the right people and I
feel like if I have a portfolio of
content that ranges from like the food
space to true crime documentaries
documentary yeah too you know the short
films that could be proof of concepts
for real films and maybe there's like a
network partnership or maybe there's a
partnership with like a bigger Network
or something like that so
I just kind of seen what 50 did and I
respect the [__] out what he did but I
don't want to have to rely on like
networks the whole time I'd rather kind
of build my own portfolio in the
background and do a partnership with the
network of of content that I own and
produce myself I was gonna say I think
we had talked about you maybe doing a
movie or something that kind of covered
the bipping aspect of the bay yeah
actually my my partners in that the
script is done it's called uh it's
called a Splash City they're coming here
they'll probably be here in like 30
minutes so as soon as we're done with
our interview and tour then I'm gonna
sit down with them review this script
but that script's ready
um there's another script ready as well
so yeah just you know taking my time to
[__] what it do right yeah I feel like
you know that is like one of the things
that like a soul Bay Area specific that
when I talk to people like they don't
know even they've never even heard the
word bit but they're like what the [__]
is that like it's such a they get here
and they get their [__] hit and I feel
like it's gonna be like the new school
New Jersey Drive almost in my opinion
yeah it's gonna be dope because no one's
really covering the Bay Area and that's
kind of my goal I feel like all right I
made it to a certain status I feel like
I put on hard with the music as much as
I could and I'ma still [__] with it but
I feel like my ultimate goal is to kind
of put the band my back in the sense of
telling some of these stories yeah
tapping into some of this Untold content
like no one's ever attached to the Bay
like all the crime films and movies are
based on New York La Chicago Boston
right yeah you know like where's the Bay
Area stories at right and so I feel like
I'm trying to get into a position like
financially and you know just respect
wise where people trust me with those
stories that'd be hard dude
um I haven't we haven't talked on camera
since you made the Forbes Magazine so I
just want to say congrats that [__]
thank you that [__] is pretty gnarly to
like the like damn my boys are like my
friend is on the cover of Forbes you
know the cool thing about that it's like
there's people that are way richer than
me and there's people that have built
way bigger businesses but to touch that
cover is like every businessman
entrepreneur's dream yeah so I have guys
like worth like hundreds of millions of
dollars they'd be like dog you did it
I'm like bro you did it [__] no
you did it for real yeah you got it got
it right now liquid but I just think
it's a it's a really cool thing to come
out of cancer and then touch that cover
and then get that age award and get a
couple other things that we got like
it's just really cool and it's just good
morale for like the kind of industry I'm
in I was gonna say how does that change
your life being on that cover because
I'm sure it makes people look at you a
lot different two ways yeah no I mean
one people put more respect on the
business conversations but two everyone
thinks you just got it got it got it
like they just seen that word like 400
million dollars to say oh [__]
you could tell me to give you let me get
a half a meal let me get let me
behind my company I know you guys like
bro like yo like this this this
valuation that they're putting on me as
a person
um you know kind of like relies on the
businesses performing executing and like
you know exiting one day right that's
what the value of my business is and so
it's kind of put a lot of things in
perspective you see even the rich rapper
list that [__] was trippy that [__] is
crazy because yeah fourth or fifth I
wasn't before crazy and then you put
yourself next to rappers like um [__]
Dr Dre yeah Dr Dre Jay-Z Kanye oh Diddy
and like people like well man burns not
really rapper like wait a minute hold up
I do got 49 albums out I've been rapping
since 2006. people are saying well he
got other businesses whoa so is that
what was everybody else everybody else
got you know uh at a time to rock and
and you know Roc Nation and I mean yeah
Ace of Spades whatever you call it the
same thing it's the same exact thing
except the differences I'm Mexican and
I'm [__] low-key underdog okay so
it's cool as [__] to see that they
recognize me on that list because that
list I always dreamed about
um about being on a list like that and I
always said that that people are
overlooking what I built and I just
remember one day kind of just throwing a
fit on Twitter like man I wish they
would look at my [__] and someone
actually was like well I'd be down the
audio and that's a really deep audit
they have to look at everything that you
have your assets your businesses it's
like a real they can't just put that
[__] out to make the cash is it the Cash
Kings this is not what they call it not
just just uh hip-hop uh Health you know
wealthiest whatever it may be
um top five wealthiest you know so they
did that and yeah that [__] hit so they
like really like they turn over all the
pages and look into your [__] for real
for real yeah they do like a real audit
of you for sure oh wow yeah it ain't no
fugazi ass number going out there no no
hell no no that's that's a real number
it's a real situation it's a real it's
just all around real like they're not
gonna they're not gonna play you on that
like right they're not going to play
themselves it's real Publications with
real credible writers and just you know
they're they're not playing they're not
playing no games with that list that
list is very strategic it's very they do
a good job of due diligence you know I
have to have them talk to like business
managers and the people that do my taxes
and yeah that shit's real damn they're
like talking to CPA and all that [__]
CPAs are looking at like properties
they're looking at the actual like oh
you say your business worth this like
let's let's do actual audit of your
business and do it you know let's get a
proper of what what did you raise that
last time you raised you know like it's
it's real as [__] it's crazy because
you've um obviously you know we've kind
of seen cookies grow from like
you know I remember the first time I
smoked cookies was with two chains and
probably
2010. shout out to Teddy Brooks yeah
that was around the time the Yoko was
getting played on the radio out there
when I was on the right that was that
was around that time and I remember
you'd be coming out to Vegas kicking
with Franny and [__] and um
I kind of had like really got hip to you
but it's just wild to see like
the like was there ever a point in time
let's say in 2010 11 where you ever
could imagine that you'd be turning down
some of the exits I'm sure you've
already been offered and and you'd be on
the cover of a publication like Forbes
did you ever see it nah but I always
knew too like at the end of the day it's
all about how much work you put into
your craft right like if you stay
dedicated to your craft if man like even
last night dude I got home last night
and I just passed the [__] out hard 9
p.m out like dead body my girls you
remember how you fell asleep I'm like
nah she's like man you were [__] out
and just because I just work all day
long
so
I never pictured me in this position
because I was always an underdog I felt
like I always had to prove myself to
somebody I always had to work harder
than others but I also knew that like
one of my first
True Believers in what I do like one of
my first actual like investors and
partners and
you know he told me he's like bro like I
don't really quite know where you're
trying to go with the rap but I do know
one thing he's like bro you don't stop
and people that don't stop in no clear
the ones that hit so I'm gonna stick
with you you should just stick with the
pack you're good at selling pack I want
bags from you and I think that you'd be
better off just focus on selling bud but
like man you just won't stop with this
rap [__] and so I have to stay behind
you I'm gonna keep pushing you because
that that's what [__] like you
aren't gonna lose and that stuck with me
I'm like you're right even the current
state of cannabis right now like the Wii
game is [__] up
a lot of people falling out a lot of
people suing each other a lot of people
hating each other a lot of business is
going under a lot of growth failing a
lot of stores failing
um
you know but we're still relevant as
hell we're still going because we still
put that passion into it like we still
care about this [__] do you think it's
also because you guys have a dope
business model I think too which is not
necessarily dependent on any because I'm
sure if people don't understand like you
guys will part like you guys have
Partners all over the country right it's
not like if you see a cookie store in
Detroit it's the same as the cookie
store in Oklahoma well some and I'm sure
some places it is the same partnership
right but for you guys like you guys
have kind of like put put together such
an incredible business model on the
storefront side at least where you know
um it's a quality control situation
where you obviously have to vet whoever
you partner with but at the same time it
kind of puts you guys in a position
where you know people are buying into
the name and the brand because the brand
is so prestigious yeah it's like ass
it's an asset like business model we're
not raising hundreds and millions of
dollars which allows me to stay in
control a lot of other people that raise
hundreds and millions of dollars in the
skin yeah they lose all their Equity I
maintaining a lot of Mac where you grow
a lot and but what it does is like it
does three things we're able to say ass
asset light we're able to expand faster
anyone else we're also able to cherry
pick the best operators and and we'll in
each market as they open up so
you know Albuquerque New Mexico we
opened up 11-3 right November 3rd that's
probably one of our best menus in the
whole country the weed looks almost
better than some of the wheat in
California the menu is extensive 30
genetics on the menu store fully built
out like we gotta cherry pick those
partners that would dedicated to us
Nirvana and Arizona I was gonna say it
took you a very long time to get to
Arizona and that was a passionate
you know we [__] up the first time we
did we did a deal with the only players
in the game and they pretty much [__]
the weed up right they [__] the weed
up but they also shelved our growth but
now we found some independent guys that
you know the team at Nirvana they
understand what this brand means they
put the quality and we turned down
enough badges until it was time to go
we're like bro it's not hitting this
boom you got it yeah and they dialed it
in and they dialed in even more from the
opening and so it allows us to partner
with the right people all around the
country
and a lot of people say it's like a
franchise it's not like a franchise
because anyone can open up McDonald's
yeah you guys are being selective on who
you're gonna let we're being selective
about who we're gonna [__] with we're
being selective on which markets are
mature enough to open up and we're also
just really understanding that like
there's nothing easy about managing
hundreds of Partners right it'd be
easier to raise the money and to build
out your [__] yourself in theory because
then you're the one controlling all that
there's a lot of egos there's a lot of
there's a lot of politics there's a lot
of personal
um you know interaction you have to do
when you have that many partners but I
like that [__] yeah and it also kind of
removes the like bureaucracy that you
would have to deal with in each City and
Market because at the end of the day
like you said in the Wii game it's
unfortunately it's full of like a lot of
cool people but it's also full like on
the corporate side bro like it's trash
bro like
I miss medical days so much
you know when it was medical it was a
big risk still and people were having to
put their neck on the line and it just
was a lot more pure as soon as it went
legal a bunch of people had no business
being in this business got in this
business and they started getting in you
know Partnerships with Legacy guys and
kind of changing the way that they think
and what's really the real goal I mean
if you look at the two things I'm truly
passionate about food and weed it's
two things that really bring people
together no matter where you're from no
matter where you're at in the world you
can connect over food or wheat right so
like I'm in it for a bigger purpose I
know the brand has value I know there's
going to be some money associated with
this with this position later on in life
but for right now it's a struggle to
maintain to stay relevant to deal with
all these different partners make sure
everyone's happy everyone feels like
they're getting the attention they need
but I wouldn't I wouldn't change our
business model or the situation we have
over anything it's cool to connect with
people all over the world and you said
it not just in the country but all over
the world
we're about to open up London uh you
know medical side of London
um we're in Spain we're in Amsterdam
we're in Israel we're selling wheat in
Germany right now like it's cool to
connect with people all over the world
over some of you created from you know
the ground up in your house it's cool
it's wild man yeah you obviously went
through like some public disputes with
some more Partners uh that were coming
out trying to sue you
um did you end up getting any of that
resolve what's the latest with that no
those things take years and those things
are like mentally training and
financially draining but like
you know I said it and I I can only talk
with very little on it but like I I know
100 that we're on the right and that
when everything comes to life people
will be like damn that boy went through
all that for what right and so I feel
very confident Where We Are No One's
Gonna Come Take cookies from me I am
cookies right no one's going to remove
any of the partners that helped me build
this along the way
and I think that's part of the
unfortunate thing about building
something big is when you build
something big people will try to come
take that [__] but growing up I didn't
give up my lunch at school I'm not going
to start doing it now and I'm also not
going to jeopardize what we all build
together as a community because
a lot of people feel attached to cookies
and I mean a lot of people got tattoos
there's a man in Tucson right now with
your portrait and the cookies logo on
his belly yeah no that's that's real
right that's a real human being I saw
him yeah and so the easy way out would
be just to bow down and take something
from them and just step but like no dude
people are fully invested in this vision
and this brand and what we built
together it's not just my [__] it's our
[__]
all these operators around the world
they believed in what we built together
right so I'm fighting for it bro and I
feel like we're going to win at the end
of the day I feel like we're going to
come out on top it's just going to take
a lot of mental strength it's going to
take a lot of capital right right that's
why we stay grinding and it's gonna just
take dedication and loyalty from me and
my partners That's it man how do you
deal with um coming at it getting
through cancer and then having to deal
with just a whole nother hurdle
obviously you got you know stuff in your
personal life going on as well you know
you you it just you know you got to have
some mental fortitude to really
get on the other side of a battle with
cancer well the defective thing is that
that lawsuit started as soon as I got
sick so that would so they were both
happening at the same time yeah like one
I found out I was sick it kind of
conversations kind of happened when I
was knee-deep in chemo and I was really
really really sick this ain't a sympathy
card at all just like yo people can
relate to what it feels like being sick
and thinking you're gonna die and also
having threats of your business being
taken right it's like it was on purpose
hey man wild timing on their end right
right maybe they didn't plan it that way
but that's the way it worked out and so
it was kind of tough but like it really
put everything in perspective for me I'm
like well first of all I really gotta
stick around right like I'm really not
gonna have to I can't go nowhere now and
it's really really made me realize like
the good precious moments like you know
with a pure things outside of business
and so
you know for me that's why the Cubs that
Forbes cover felt good coming out of
that [__] it was like man I'm being
recognized I'm getting my flowers while
I'm here that's why the ad age award the
Cleo award these are all big you know
big
[__] globally recognized platforms
that are recognizing what we're doing
and so it just was the motivation I
needed to keep fighting but cancer was
really really hard on me I had major
PTSD from that [__] and I'm noticing
more and more people getting colon
cancer the young ass age and it's just
scary bro it's just like really really
like a lot of men don't go and get
checked for that [__] nah because the
symptoms are so I had zero symptoms I
had early stage three colon cancer that
means another six months of letting that
ride would have took my ass out so I
probably would have had a year or so if
I would have waited six months or more
to even get checked I probably would
have had a year or two years at most the
hardest thing for me to watch was like
the the brother you know shout out to
his whole family
um his kids and his wifey but you know
seeing the inky boys go through that we
found out at the same time you know what
I mean and
I'm just like damn bro like that [__]
hurt and it hit hard because I'm like
damn not everyone's gonna have a chance
to make it through this and so I just
take a lot more calmer approach on life
and like stress and I just I feel
blessed to even be here bro and that's
why I try to tell people when people get
stressed out about money and things
that's going on but today's world of my
bro like yeah [__] stuff but you're
alive man like you can't you can't even
downplay how big that is right now for
sure brother that is I think that some
people forget that what was the um like
what made you get tested for for it was
it just like a normal run-of-the-mill
doctor's visit nah because I was with
the doctor already that wouldn't even
have ever looked for that it was like
some weird like Universal gut feeling I
I just had I just woke up one day was
looking out my window my damn I actually
got a good life here things are going
good I'm successful I feel like cookies
is going to be something incredible
that's going to live forever like what
am I actually missing in life that where
am I missing at I'm like
maybe Health like I'm you know I'm
losing a little weight I'm not as big as
I used to be but maybe I should like get
myself a private doctor to really look
into what I got going on because you
know I just want to make sure I'm good
it's crazy because five years before
this I had a fear of having a stomach
cancer like my mom I went and got a
colonoscopy 100 clean wow so five years
so in five years in five years that
cancer developed and got to early stage
three and so
I picked a random ass um I picked a
random ass day that called my partner
Parker and asked him do we know any
concierge doctors any private doctors
that could actually care about me as a
human or really looking at me and we
found a doctor that was not only you
know willing to take me home but he's
also investor into our business and he's
the only doctor in the country that does
his test the gallery test so when I went
to go see him he was like yo we can run
you know all your blood work and make
sure you're good but like
this new test came out two months ago I
want to run on you and test for cancer
for 50 types of cancer student blood I'm
like let's run it and that's how you
found this [__] and the article came out
like maybe like three weeks ago I'm kind
of like one of the first people that
publicly took that test found that I had
cancer addressed it and made it through
the situation so there's a big debate
about this test right now not a lot of
doctors want to take it on because
false positives that's the craziest
shoot I've ever heard in my life I saw
it work for me it saved me that's why
I'm here right now and I appreciate
about this every time I get a chance
that that test should be available so it
feels like an easy test to take too like
in terms of like what do you think like
yeah it's a blood test blood test and I
would rather get a false positive and
think I'm going to have cancer for a
week and a half until they go look
inside my body and then find out that
I'm good right then like not know
anything at all yeah because you got
doctors that are doctors are I mean man
you got good doctors you got doctors who
are just getting a check it's like
teachers I look at doctors and teachers
kind of it's like anything in business
doctors being a doctor's business and
you know some of the institutions like
even though they're good doctors they
just don't have the bandwidth like if
you're at Kaiser Permanente you're
seeing 4 000 patients right how could
you actually truly keep up with one of
those patients facts like even if you're
a really good person even if you don't
have a hidden agenda
yeah you can't your bandwidth is going
to be done you're not gonna be able to
keep track of everything and so you know
for all my people out there with money
they got money that care about their
health you know the new flex is getting
concierge doctor okay yeah all the rad
cats out there living fast on the road
not eating so well like
yo [__] that Gucci belt [__] that [__]
that new whip you know [__] [__] that
new chain [__] get yourself a
concierge doctor make sure you pay
attention to your health that's the new
flex really that's some real [__] hey so
you've you've made so much money over
the years what are some of the I always
wonder when people because I started to
make like money where I need to
figure out every year how to not pay
taxes
what are some of the the tips the
tidbits you've picked up in the last
decade or so since you've been uh
dealing with you know certain quantities
of legal money you know the thing is I I
know a lot of [__] you could do but I'm
just too stubborn to change my lifestyle
like you could live in Miami you could
live in Nevada you could live in places
where you don't stay taxed you could
live in Puerto Rico and pay zero tax but
like do I want to change the quality of
my lifestyle to save a little bit of
bread after cancer especially hell no
yeah I'm just gonna pay you know it is
frustrating you get a million dollar
check you got to give over 50 of that to
the government right at the top like if
I got 20 million dollars right now I'm
gonna have to give over 10 million
dollars to the government right now for
what because we live in Canada right but
I'm not going to use any of those tricks
now the one thing I just learned
recently is that you're allowed a gift
up to x amount of money a year you know
without it without it being taxed you
know to someone you love so I'm gonna
start making sure every year I put x
amount of money as a gift aside from my
kid it's tax free at least you could
have that yeah so that's one thing I
learned yeah but otherwise like it's
really all about like
where you live and where you reside and
like things you could write off and the
[__] up thing is because I'm burned
because I'm cookies I get audited every
year anyways so I'm sure they just find
it so your [__] has to be like super
buttoned up but you know if you get a
tour of us like your bus that's a big
ass right off you know yeah no it is for
the business it is it's a good way to
travel it's a good way to Brand your
[__] too so you know I would just say
like look man just pay attention to your
[__] if you go out eat take pictures
your receipts if you're paying cash you
can write off a lot of things as an
Entertainer your outfits you know
something some of the things you got to
do yeah yeah
for sure uh yo I gotta ask you you're a
big alien guy and recently things have
gotten like it feels like for whatever
reason the last like 12 to 18 months
they keep kind of just like sprinkling
little like breadcrumbs
preparing us for the inevitable in my
opinion
you know whether it's the uh well that
hearing what that dude who blew the you
know the he pretty much said that we're
in possession of
uh Alien aircraft or whatever the hell
and then there's the Mexican uh two look
I don't know I don't know how legit that
one was I believe that [__] I believe it
too I believe it um I mean look if you
go back like maybe seven or eight years
ago there was that guy who was in the
Canadian Parliament talking about it
um but yeah man like this [__] is crazy
like when you saw the Mexican aliens
like what were your thoughts because
they really rolled them out like an
official Mexican government like nah
that shit's official here's the problem
with the world we've been lied to and
[__] with for so long that every
single time someone posts something it's
just memes and and people just turns
into social media jokes and and that's
what they want yeah they don't want us
to think like yo there's a there's a
bigger purpose out there there's
something that we totally don't even
know about there's not there's something
that maybe hire people in our in our
civilization actually communicate with
and get game from if you look how fast
the world grew went from [__] riding
horses to whips and iPhones and [__] for
in a small amount of time that's coming
from somewhere some genius decisions
just wake up like I can [__] make it
so we can boom boom nah we're getting
game from somewhere right and so
I believe that [__] I also believe that
they're never going to tell us what's
real they're probably just trying to
prepare us for some kind of [__]
agenda but there's a lot of Truth in
some of that [__] as well so I if if
it's me talking
I know there's a bigger purpose out here
the gut feeling I got that day to go
find a concert here Dr bro I'm what the
[__] like right that was bigger than
just like me thinking that I should get
a private doctor there's no reason why
on that day I even felt that in here in
your gut your second brain right
um I've been watching like a lot of
near-death experience stuff because
obviously I had a near-death experience
in my opinion I didn't just die and wake
up but like I came close to it so and
watching all that stuff I just
understand there's bigger purpose as as
conscious as like the Universe goes and
so
I believe that little alien was real I
believe that Mexico was the first ones
actually stop something they've been
holding I feel like all these
civilizations are uncovering like in uh
and you know in the jungles and [__] all
these different pyramids were seeking
man ain't no humans built that [__] Bro
[__] out of here bro yeah it's crazy
like it's crazy too that like some of
them are so they they match up other
pyramids that are so far apart well they
align with the Stars perfectly they're
all they're all like in strategic ass
you know places in the world that like
will line up with like the universe
perfectly and I I mean whatever also I
know that humans have dumbed down hard
since back in the day it's like and
that's what they want like they put so
much [__] and propaganda and they've
created the word like conspiracy
theories and and all that stuff so that
way that things that are real like look
at all the people in my seen UFOs back
in the days it made them seem like
[__] loony bins dude for sure I mean
I think of like just like if you were to
go back 20 years and if some of this
news would have broke how big of a deal
it'd be compared to now and now it's
like no one cares because no one gives a
[__] whatever [__] they're
worried about like how to make the next
dollar or who's bitching or who or a
[__] what Kim Kardashian was doing
yeah they're worried about some [__]
that's like yo my man they just showed
an alien from like I was an alien
there's a thousand years ago a proofs
were not alone that little [__]
look real as [__] and like they're happy
seeing them comments right now the thing
is is like I think once people really
like have to realize
there'll be a moment where they have to
really like be like oh it kind of like
it you know for me I know it's gonna
make a lot of people who grew up super
religious who grew up believing certain
things it's going to kind of poke a lot
of random holes in there dude besides
all that have you ever seen Judah in the
black Messiah yeah all right like look
how the government did damn bro look how
they did the Panthers right 100 like bro
they will do things to [__] you off
right like I'm not gonna say no names I
don't want no smoke or nobody but I
think there's people in ours in our
culture right now that cause a lot of
trouble on the on the internet and with
other celebrities I believe they're
working for the CIA
that's that's my honest being I'm like
yo there's no way this guy is constantly
trying to tempt people and throw people
off their game and get them to say or do
other things that might put them in jail
it's been the agenda against minorities
for a long time yeah it's crazy I think
like there is some sort of like and and
like you said that word conspiracy
theorists has gotten um it's gotten to
the point where like
you can't question anything without
being called crazy dude they have fact
Checkers dog well and to me it's like
you know I remember when
conspiracy theories were like 9 11 and
you'd be like oh you know let me look
into this but now it's like if you
question anything they put you in that
box like I look at um
you know RFK Jr who's somebody who I I I
think is dope you know I've watched his
interviews and I don't think he's said
anything crazy you know what I mean I
just think he's just a curious dude
who's once the question [__] but they
are so
they just put them in that box and then
people who don't do the the work or the
like my mom like I told my mom I was
like hey I [__] with RFK and she was
like he's a [__] kook he's crazy and
I was like have you ever heard him speak
like he's asking he's at least
addressing real world issues yeah yeah
he's addressing the fact that like
multiple corporations really run
everything which is great
what should be the number one thing
everyone should be worried about that's
a concern Monopoly sucks
and State Street are like kind of
running your entire life
and no one's talking about it but but
that also might be the reason why he's
he's getting boxed out you know I mean
he's the only presidential candidate
that doesn't have secret service at his
disposal and someone tried to just run
up on him yeah so you know the world is
full of hidden agendas the more older
you get the more money you touch the
more [__] you deal with like the
[__] I'm doing with these lawsuits and
Powerful groups and big money guys you
realize that yo this shit's real dog
like it's it's different yeah it's
different it's definitely different uh
you mentioned having 49 albums I always
say this uh when we talk about just
consistency as an emcee as a rapper as
an artist I feel like you're one of the
most consistent guys in the game you've
always been extremely I mean no matter
what was going on in your life you you
always have the time to you know hone in
and create and make an album more collab
with an artist to make a project
um
for you uh like you know obviously it's
a passion thing but like for whatever
reason does it still bother you that
maybe you don't get the acknowledgment
or the accolades or the flowers as a
wrapper that you do for all the other
[__] nah because I knew if I put 100
energy behind music it'd probably be a
lot bigger right and I'll argue with my
DJ you know Teflon this tour about
changing our setup and trying new things
and I just told them I said bro it's a
bandwidth issue at this point like I'm
running cookies clothing I'm running
cookies at weed business I'm running
Vibes papers I'm running you know this
compound and our media is you know out
company that we're trying to build and I
only have so much time for music I told
music is my therapy bro like I don't
really look at like it's my business if
I treat it more like a business I'd
probably make way more money I'd
probably get way more respect I've had
people like two chains black bro like
why don't you be like our
like Mexican version of Rick Ross like
you got that talk you got that respect
like people [__] with you but you're not
putting enough respect on like your
image and the way I'm sorry I promise is
a real dude bro I don't really be
tripping off like
really trying to build myself as this
big old as a facade yeah like like
you're not a character no I just feel
like music is a good it's a good therapy
for me it's a challenge for me to still
to try to stay relevant after all this
time it's a it's a way for me like to be
creative outside of like all this other
stuff I have fun doing it but I don't
treat like my number one priority I feel
like if I did I could be like a French
Montana or something like that right
like I could be looked at as like a
bigger artists right I could wear
jewelry every day and glasses and be
fitted up but like I'm comfortable in
this sweatshirt right now I'm rich as
[__] yeah I don't need to show
it right like for what like my new flex
is not to flex I got a pair of earrings
on but I'm not wearing my you know 20
different rings I'm not wearing big old
chains or I'm not really worried about
my outfit so much I don't give a [__]
all the billionaires I meet look like
[__] bumps they pull up looking real
humble and some dress down that [__] and
that's how that's what I want to be like
at this point like bro have you seen the
whip I'm driving in right now I gave the
Maybach truck back on my bro [__] all
this flashy [__] I got it there's no the
world knows I got it so why why even try
to prove it anymore hey what up we gotta
stop the interview to tell you about our
folks and my bookie that's right now
look
I'm a big Gambler love gambling love
sports gambling I have been on a tear
look I ain't gonna lie to y'all NFL
season so far been real good to your boy
you could get down go to mybookie.ag
sign up right now with that promo code
bootleg and uh you know what's great
about that promo code is it's going to
get you hooked up with uh 50 or more
your first deposit you can get up to 200
in cash straight to your my bookie
account with the promo code bootleg at
the end of the day Aaron Rodgers season
is a wrap my guy tore his Achilles it's
over your season doesn't have to be over
NFL college ball man the new cash out
system on my book is crazy let's say you
got a three leg par leg a four leg
parlay maybe three of the four legs have
hit and you're waiting maybe on Monday
Night Football to see if you hit all
four but you don't want to take that
risk you just want to cash out take your
money and run you can do it that brand
new cash out system is fire alright so
make sure you go to my bookie right now
man so much to do all kinds of daily
odds boosters same game parlays huge
prize pool contest right now
mybookie.ag all right sign up use the
promo code bootleg on your first deposit
of 50 or more you can get up to 200 in
cash instantly to gamble with plus we
got a shout out to our fam at
blue chew that's right this is a good
thing about Bluetooth guys
well one you know the one thing I always
get asked about Bluetooth is one does it
work
two do you use it well yes on both
Accords all right shout out to Bluetooth
it works but you gotta that not take my
word for it get a whole month for free
right now if you go to bluetooth.com and
use that promo code bootleg they're
gonna send you a month's supply of
Bluetooth straight to your door for free
just gotta pay five dollars shipping
same active ingredient as Viagra and
Cialis and when I tell you that your
dick is going to be [__] your Johnson
is going to be johnsoning
your [__] is going to be rocked up
socked up and ready to unload yeah it's
like Barry Bonds seven he was a 73 home
runs 70 home run season you're gonna be
knocking them [__] right over the
[__] ho what's what's the Big Green
Monster in Fenway Park [__] your dick's
gonna be hitting hitting that [__]
straight over that wall you know what
I'm saying or whatever you're into you
know they don't gotta be [__] you could
be [__] whatever you're into
bluetooth.com put your best foot forward
when it comes to your dick all right you
don't want to go on a first date with a
young lady who you think is you know
easy enough to [__] on the first date
and not be prepared get the Bluetooth
bluetooth.com promo code bootleg and get
your first month for free same active
ingredient as Viagra Cialis no awkward
doctor's appointment uh it's all online
discreet packaging straight to your door
in a chewable Forum bluetooth.com promo
code bootleg let's get back to the
interview now I feel you I'm on that
same [__] when I mean obviously I'm much
lower over and lower level but like yeah
I'm I'm not uh
you know I have I own a nightclub now in
Scottsdale you bet you were there but my
partners man they love the Beamers and
they get they get like that's just oh I
feel like that's just you're just
rubbing that [__] in people's faces I
don't care yeah I don't care my wife has
a nice whip I drive my car uh that I
that I don't mind driving to the bay and
putting miles on and you know my wife is
sitting nice and I feel like I feel like
right now we've learned a lot like
recipes to p and B bro like a recipe to
all these other situations all these
other people that are losing their lives
but like I feel like right now the
world's in the most [__] up position
we've seen it in in our generation
besides 2008 people are broke people are
hurting it feels it does feel though the
energy is not the same in terms of like
the literal losses happening in oh wait
but it feels almost like like you could
feel it the amount of calls I get every
day for people trying to get money or
trying to figure out ways to make money
or people feeling the loss of like
emotion is crazy and so I don't want to
be the one to be rubbing no [__] in
people's faces right now I'd rather just
stay low-key do my thing but as far as
music goes I'm gonna keep trying like
I'm gonna keep doing my thing having fun
with it I know me and ogz are locked in
for next month and I got a AEP which
will be dope bring some good young
energy around yeah for sure you know
you've let him use the bus before yeah
that's my little bro right and I think
he's super dope and I'm like let me get
next to OG's and just kind of soak up
some of that energy real quick I already
got the Beats picked out yeah you know
Rory called me the other day he's like
bro like do we need someone to pick me
some my bro bro you are there's one
thing you do well you pick [__] beats
man for me in no Jeezy project I got
some [__] you are great you You're great
a r yeah that's what I told Roy yes I
said bro I don't like to say this too
often but I I got us that record you
dropped one of my favorite records you
dropped recently it was you uh Conway
Jada who was on that record it was me
Conway Mozzy Mozzy uh
um Styles P no it wasn't Jade it was
thousands Styles P and that [__] was
crazy yeah [__] was hard but I got the
Mino gz project lined up I got uh me and
Larry June want to do another one but I
want I told my mom to take the time and
have all live music being played so we
could perform that [__] with the bands
oh that'll be hard me and Mozzy got
another one coming I already got me
individuals too yeah I already got the
Beats picked me and Bureau got a full
album already done produced by Scott
Storage I just need to find the time to
like add like two more hooks maybe like
three features well you wouldn't be real
haven't done anything for a while I mean
at least officially yeah it's what it's
been like six seven years
Los medos was the last one okay that was
a great album just happened during coven
and we've got 49 like you know we got
discouraged because the album was so
good but then for Kobe we just got
[__] on the promo for it but yeah
Amino Jeezy I got me and Mazi got me
Larry June I got me and be real I'm
gonna bring one back with my brother
ampuccino you know for old school
purposes just old school mob sound but
I'm going all group projects right now
for a while I feel like I've done a good
amount of solos I'm just like let me
just go group projects and just bring
different energies up
um have you had the opportunity to tap
in or meet or at least check out Mexican
OT yeah I mean
I was supposed to be involved in this
project something fell to the cracks but
I got a call about like you know
potentially helping a r his project
um and like sitting with him and helping
pick beasts and come up with just like
features and things like that because
someone else recognized Chinese
scientists recognize the talent for the
year but something got lost in
communication but
he's a good kid I still want the
opportunity though because I feel like
he's a dope ass artist he has a lot of
potential he's blown the [__] up and I
feel like you know [__] if I just sat
with him for one album if I gotta bring
out some [__] he don't even know he got
yet and I feel like he's got a good
sound he's got a good look he's got like
a good momentum but
[__] OT I know the first project thing
slip through the cracks I'm running a
billion dollar business it wasn't on
purpose if you hear this sit down with
me for one project bro I promise I bring
a whole different world out for you
brother just on some just a whole
different vibe with their production
with the features with the rollout like
and you know I think that kid's got a
lot of potential yo I wonder like you
sitting back and kind of seeing because
we're talking about how like you know
for whatever reason the bait gets
overlooked when he was thinking like
stories and how you know it gets covered
I mean I think lately unfortunately most
of the stuff we hear about the bay in
the news world like Nationwide is real
negative you know it's [__] up out
here
um whether it's the Smashing grabs or
the the bipping or you know whatever the
case is for you like what do you think
is you know because because if you go
through the city if you go into San
Francisco it's a lot different place
than it was in five years ago four years
ago you know what I mean like for you
what do you think is um the remedy and
what do you think is the cause of kind
of all the chaos in in the bay right now
man it's gonna be a touchy subject bro
but I'm just gonna be real bro because
at the end of the day I'm not I didn't
make it this far to stay Asylum about
things I think they just let the city go
to [__] on purpose they justify the [__]
out of San Francisco they moved all the
people that are from there out of there
so the actual care and love is not
really there anymore from people that
grew up in neighborhoods like Hunter's
Point or you know Lakeview or the
Fillmore District or the mission they
just moved everyone out they brought big
Tech in big Tech got spoiled they got
you know they started turning the city
into what they want to even the
neighborhood I grew up in on California
and Fillmore my dad's restaurant used to
be on top of our on the bottom of our
apartment complex and then there would
be like a movie store there'd be a pizza
shop there'd be a coffee shop there'd be
this Mexican restaurant it's all
Boutique clothing stores and I was like
who the [__] what the [__] this ain't a
neighborhood no more this is something
like I am techie yeah Shin so I think
the biggest problem with SF is that it
got gentrified and they got way too
liberal like bro I like how liberal the
bear is I grew up getting money because
of the laws of how liberal it is but
brother Smash and grab [__] some some
chump ass here bro and like the fact
they just let it ride like that like the
fact you could walk into Walgreens and
just take whatever you want and walk out
and not worry about going to jail it's
[__] because at the end of the day
we got kids and I want my kids to feel
safe when they go do their thing in the
city like if your daughter 18 19 because
she's getting there right she's 16. yeah
you know you would not feel comfortable
with her going shopping by herself in
San Francisco I send somebody whatever
because I know what it is I know that
there's a risk for a car to get broken
into I know there's a risk for someone
to steal someone out of my hand and just
move and so
this is the Bay Area y'all we grew up
selling packs getting money out of the
[__] we grew up you know doing what we
had to do we're real Hustlers we're this
home of the independent blueprint for
sure E40 JT the bigger figure we own our
own masters we were we were taught how
to hustle from our mouthpiece I feel
like that's where I am where I am in
life is because I was bred by the real
ones with real game bringing back to
that dude go pick up go go get back with
this [__] man go hate to say it as a
father of a Teenage one bro go break a
[__] go go go sell a pack go go build
an independent [__] portfolio music
go go do something dope man like all
this other [__] is hella Petty it's just
it's trash and like that's not what we
represent I see some big players
speaking out on it
some real ones that did a lot of time
out of the Oakland area shout out to
Little D I mean shots the real ones the
real players we're players in the Bay
Area we're go-gitters we're independent
Hustlers we're we're a different breed
to aim when I was just put that respect
back on the area because right now we
look like a bunch of little petty ass
tees and that's not what it is you know
it's crazy I have this talk all the time
because you know I'm a [__] pretty
liberal dude you know like I voted
Democrat most of my life or my whole
life me too
um and you know it's like
it's like at what point in time it's
like yeah what do we do I feel like
they're getting too liberal bro they're
letting this [__] fall and this is my
time [__] like it's like that's coming
to La October 1st I'm like y'all think
La is bad right now yeah but let me tell
you why though I'm I'm a I'm a priest
man I feel like they're doing this [__]
on purpose so they can Implement other
laws that way supersede any of this [__]
so y'all can get away with some [__]
right now keep [__] up our program
keep making us look crazy
they're gonna come in like you know what
due to all these problems we're going to
put in this law right here this boom
boom boom boom boom and we're gonna buy
whoa so everyone's right now it's like
the show like your scan your ID before
you even enter a mall soon it just I
feel like China is leading the way for
like the social credit score [__]
they're leading the way for like this
non
real lifestyle like they're monitoring
they're the real big brother right now
and I feel like what they're doing in
the U.S especially in in Democratic
areas is they're letting this [__] fall
apart on purpose so they can Implement
bigger laws that just affect and take
all of our freedom away that's just my
opinion I could be high maybe guys I've
been smoking a little too much there's
something to be said about like that
social credit score [__] because it
already kind of feels like it's
happening like [__] yeah it's happening
look at Instagram dog you act wrong you
speak about something they don't want
you to speak about you get Shadow banned
they tell you we're only showing your
content to xmi why who's deciding this
[__] that's that big brother [__] that's
why you should join Social Club
[__] [__] how's Social Club
doing it's too tough bro uh I mean bro
we built out an app that allows you to
upload pictures videos text posts
you could put your whole menu if you're
a Trapper or if you have a store you can
put your whole menu of products and
price for free attached to your profile
or putting audio comments and audio
caption right no other platformer has
that but no one will will [__] with the
platform I'm burnt out on it I'm
thinking about giving up on it again
that's the one business I can't figure
out which is tough man it's tough
because like you're competing with like
I mean but think about this though we're
competing with a platform that doesn't
give a [__] about any of us our shit's
Shadow band I had someone at Facebook
tell me yo you got two million followers
you should be at 13 million followers by
all the ways you've been searched all
the stuff that you've done the
accomplishments you've made there's no
way I was stuck at 1.9 million followers
for two years you mean to tell me I was
on the cover of forest magazine and my
followers didn't go up a hundred
thousand at all yeah [__] that she was
like you should be at 13 million at
least but they're capping your growth
well I think what it is man is
unfortunately like everyone's gonna go
where the attention is right so if you
are like a [__] business owner you
want to be where everybody's at it just
is what it is so it's like in the same
way that like you know
like YouTube unfortunately you know
there's other YouTube uh competitors
that have popped up that like Rumble and
[__] like that but you know it's like if
you gotta you if you got a Content
Channel you kind of have to depend on
YouTube in a certain way because you
want if you want your [__] to scale for
real that's where the eyes are it's hard
to get people to switch from Instagram
I've offered other celebrities equity
and Social Club to help me build it's
like nah man it's not gonna work you
know my bro I put
you know over what like 2.5 million
dollars in a social club so I'm trying
to give away Equity to people just help
me build it like that man it's not gonna
work yeah it's just tough because you're
competing with these guys in Santa Clara
in the Silicon Valley yeah
I mean at some point people are gonna
get sick of having their posts deleted
you know so I think I think what's gonna
happen hopefully is once weed probably
becomes federally legal there will be
probably like a need for like a real
platform like social club because
it's going to be such a
it's going to be it's just I feel like
there's there's got to be there's gonna
be a weed platform
20 years from now well if you sell weed
if you smoke weed if you post weed you
should know this 100 Mark Zuckerberg
[__] hates weed he does not want yeah
you've had your [__] yanked before I
mean I've heard it from the top I'm from
here I live in the Bay Area I know
people have worked with the homie and so
basically
he just doesn't like weed keep your keep
weed off of IG you don't want your
patience or just join a social club and
post your weed there like don't be a
[__] [__] start up an account
if you really claim you trap or die
should you put your menu up for free
right now on my [__] yeah you know [__]
[__] with me hey man Social Club I got a
profile go follow me on there yeah I got
a profile no one really interacts on
that that's a sad I'll be honest but
it's gonna take us to build it man
because I I don't even like going there
and getting like no responses I get like
40 comments and [__] but like at the end
it's a good platform if we all move over
there then it's you know [__] it is what
it is Yo you've been so good at building
Brands um I just saw Vibes clothing
launched uh I got a pack shots it owe me
a luck uh send me some gear um but
you've just been so you have a knack for
brand building and that's the talent
um you know cookies obviously is one of
the most recognizable brands in the
world at this point
um it's getting bootlegged everywhere I
go to the Santee alleys there's so much
fake cookie [__] man [__] 11 Pierre
right right go get yeah it's like a
[__] billboard for you at the end of
the day uh you go to the goddamn
whatever liquor store
just empty bags for sale for a dollar a
piece you can get your cookie bag and
stuff whatever [__] weed in there
charity as [__] you've seen those right
yeah they even have like fake Grinders
and think like uh [__] that there's
been some cool bootleg [__] I've seen
But like yeah we we're probably like one
of the most number one bootleg Brands
out there but when the weed space are
definitely number one yeah for sure but
even like on the clothing accessory side
like I'll see like fake bongs and all
kind of crazy but you know at the end
day it's like flow dude that makes me
feel good because people really want to
take their energy to kind of boot like
what I'm doing then it's like that means
you're doing something if you the brands
are not getting bootleg I have something
to worry about they should worry about
that I was gonna ask you though in terms
of like brand building what are some of
the things that like you could give some
game on in terms of maybe if somebody is
starting a new business maybe it's a
coffee shop maybe it's a pastry line
maybe it's you know what are the the
kind of the general things that you know
you would uh you would say are important
yeah I'll give you guys like three and
then the rest you gotta buy the book I
got a book on the way
uh but pretty much like first thing
first is you got to find your identity
you gotta find your logo and your
identity you see cookies got that Circle
C and we got the font on my hands you
want to find your script you want to
find your identity I think a second
thing that's important is like find the
colorway that sticks out we can paint
that building blue and you know what it
is even in markets where like they won't
let us call to building cookies I just
painted blue
you know if there's a medical Market we
opened up West Virginia we couldn't put
no signs in there but that [__] is blue
because I know exactly you know what it
is so find your identity find your
script find your colorway and I think
the third thing is like you better be
Hands-On with your [__] because if
you're not hands on with your [__]
you're never gonna actually really own
and understand your [__] you could pay
agency to build this for you can do that
for you can pay people to do marketing
but if you ain't really on the ground
building that [__] then it's not real
that's some real [__] most people like
you said though I feel like a lot of
people will settle for whatever shitty
design they get back from the graphic
designer they paid the first time
for this even deeper now I got hundreds
of employees and some of their jobs will
be like to go see quality and common
inequality but like when I see something
I'll be like can you set up a call with
the partners for me so I can call them
like yo this looks really good and it
burns pretty good but I feel like we can
do a little better and I feel like we do
ABC FG that can really bring a whole new
product out and you buy the flower yeah
but
I don't really know like if I even have
time for that but I do it and by calling
them directly they respect the [__] out
of it and they're fired up to them even
paying attention what's coming out of a
random market right
um and so I just feel like when you put
that work in yourself then people will
respect you as as that brand and you'll
actually know what's going on with your
brand I could be clueless sitting in
this building right now but yeah cookies
is great man we're [__] the biggest
and the best and yeah [__] rock on or
I could be the way I am ain't know about
everything let me see it oh man we could
change this or this short feels good but
we should do this or like are you are
they doing sales every week are they in
you know are they engaging with their
customers I'm so hands on with
everything from like design to flower to
new products to launches of products to
Partners to you know drama going on here
there I that's why the businesses still
what it is is because I know what's up
yeah you lose touch your [__] you're
[__] that's that is some real [__] I
was gonna ask you
um in terms of
you know
you've had a journey that we've all
watched very closely but there was like
a point in time where you were still
probably very much like uh
one foot in one foot out I'm like still
being the guy sending packs and trapping
hard and and and and also the guy trying
to build a business and a career as an
artist
um a lot of those things ran parallel
with each other do you remember kind of
uh
when was the first time you kind of got
like the peace sleep of like I'm out of
that life like because at the end of the
day we're still you're still in the Wii
game right so it's still the weed games
you're still going to kind of be
involved in certain type of around
certain people and [__] but in terms of
just like
really being like man I got through that
[__] you know what I mean like yeah when
I hit that 10-year Mark yeah 10 years
right I mean I think it's statue of
limitations like seven years maybe it's
ten years I don't know but after 10
years of like not being [__] with for
anything I did in the past I felt good I
mean we still get targeted I still get
profiled still get questioned and have
issues with banks and stuff like that
but like
from the little [__] I did prior in the
very beginning of my career
yeah after that 10-year Mark you know
probably you're like hey yeah you heard
about it yet I ain't gonna hear about it
you know but I just chose to walk away
at the right time my mom died there's
gonna be no one else that could look
after or love my daughter the way I
would or she would yeah and I was like
I'm out yeah that's it it took a lot of
dedication but that again that's why I
feel like the brand is what it is
because I put it all into that you could
have one foot in and one foot out
but like you're only giving that one
foot in half a tension
like bra could be the Brown Bag Boy
right now I could send packs I could get
more money for weed to anyone else I
could be I know everybody I could be
killing it but like why would I do that
when I have cookies potentially being
you know one of the biggest canvas
brands in the world as far as like being
recognized everywhere right like why do
I jeopardize that [__] and it's tough
it's tempting and I missed a brown bag
and I miss how to sing and whatnot but
like I just hustle in a different way
yeah what would uh be your advice
because we see guys like uh Jay-Z popped
up and had a baby Brandon I don't know
what happened with it because I I I
think it's called monogram I think it
kind of came and went
um but we kind of see that a version of
that happening a lot with artists
especially artists who don't necessarily
even smoke with yeah right
um what would be like you know because
because I do feel like there is a
misconception
that if you just get it get your own
strain
you know man you see it all the time we
don't even gotta say names but there's
so many rappers out here who have gone
in and out of just strain deals and
hoarded themselves out to so many
different guys and they're on Instagram
talking doing posts for people about
boxes and you see these [__] posts
terrible it's [__] crazy there are
these like yo you're getting paid by the
trapper in downtown L.A to shout out
their [__]
telegram like what are we doing here
like well first thing first like if I if
I was still sending boxes I wouldn't pay
anyone to shout me out at all that's
crazy that's crazy yeah you're snitching
on yourself so that's just I see that
[__] and I'm like what yes I'm like whoa
It's a commercial for them to come and
get you bro yeah so you know it's one
thing to shout out like a different type
of weed yeah hey I'm smoking this like
that's cool but to say hey my guy
guarantees touchdowns you need your
boxes make sure you follow so and so
like they always touch down trust me I
know so three things one if I was still
trapping the golden rules you don't even
talk about that [__] like that right
two
um you don't know who the [__] you're
validating you might be validating
someone that's got some crazy [__] if
someone can give you twenty five hundred
dollars and a half a pound of weed for
you to stamp them who knows who the [__]
they are yeah so you know artists find
deals are a little more pure like maybe
you get paid to stamp a different
genetic or you get paid to endorse a
brand but like going back to Australian
thing like a strain is only good if you
have someone that can consistently grow
good and could you know help make it
tangible in other markets and I think
the problem is that a lot of people get
in the Wii game have won never sold weed
two don't understand the wheat industry
and three don't really have enough
patience to see it through to get paid a
little bit which is the biggest thing
yeah they get paid a little bit of bread
they put their brand on the Shelf they
get a line for the first drop but then
they're not following up and a lot of
artists are so [__] conceited with
their Instagrams that they won't even
post this [__] the way they're supposed
to they're like want to post like
pictures of their chat
all right so you know I feel like
if you're going to try to get in the Wii
game understand what the Wii game is
first of all right like I've been
smoking weed forever I've been in this
game legally for like 21 years already
so it's I have an unfair advantage of
understanding what's going to work and
what won't
you know the perfect idea of a celebrity
brand that worked with Erica Badu and
I'm gonna tell you why it worked because
one she took her time I tried to
approach her many years ago she wasn't
ready yet she took her time to learn to
understand the weed business sugar time
to understand the weed culture right she
took her time to wait for a genetic that
stood out that made sense that was
different she told me what kind genetics
she wanted I told her I said sis we can
give you something that's ready already
we can start breeding and try to find
something that's that's really going to
check those boxes for you she said take
your time I'm in no rush and so it took
two years and we presented her with
flower which is like is a limoncello
cross that I really really really like
right so Erica has a real genetic right
Erica took time to understand the
business understands
um you know the culture she took time to
to develop her genetics right she also
is Hands-On as [__] and that goes back
to what we talked about earlier she's on
every single call every single creative
call she's a part of the design process
she's engaged she's part of like the
store drops she's part of like coming up
with you know new products and new names
for products she actually gives a [__] a
matter of fact we're supposed to go live
one day and promote uh one of the drops
in the New Market she said burn it I'm
[__] around and stopped my life then
Shadow bam I asked for posting the last
year Erica Badu she said I know ain't
that a [__] you know what though you're
putting in the work and so Erica's brain
worked because she understood the
purpose of it she understands it's a
medicine it actually really connects me
people she loves her she loves her
automatic it's not a lick it's not a
lick but people treat this [__] like
it's a lick it's not about money for her
at all we've never I could be honest to
say I've never discussed money with
Erica Badu about her wee business at all
everyone wants all we talked about is it
being great and resonating with the
people and it being everywhere that we
can put it and that's all she cared
about right and so her brand is going to
continue to work right and we have some
really cool products with her outside
the flower we got the mushroom tea with
her
um we got we got this crazy ass uh other
flower formula that's kind of like a I
think it's like a blue lotus or
something like that that gets you
feeling super trippy
um she's a true and like she took the
time and put the respect and for the
culture and for her audience to educate
them on what this actually is that she's
selling anyone else doing that [__] did
you ever anticipate the Gary Payton
thing becoming such a thing no where
people were like rapping about us
smoking all that Gary Payton like nah
real like Staples out it's just a bomb
ass weed yeah and Gary just made it like
even cooler and like you know the whole
story and that's again is an organic
situation because he is he's from
Oakland right he's from Oakland yeah but
like he didn't like we didn't plan that
out that was just like happened random
organically as [__] yeah and then you
see I mean every basketball player is
has got their own strain now yeah but
like again with Gary he just trusts the
process has like anybody like a guy like
Kevin Durant reached out to you to try
to kind of get some game because I do
see he's trying to get into the Wii game
a bit I've chilled with Kevin hella
times yeah yeah you know like and I I've
smoked bubble Kevin now he's openly
talking about that right yeah he's
openly talking about it so I'll say it
now because now players can smoke yeah
I've gotten big high with Kevin Durant
and I [__] with him a lot and we have a
game plan for something to do it just
depends whether he still wants to do it
or not but like I've sat with him I
spoke to him I kind of presented a plan
for him and I [__] with him because he
actually really smokes big yeah
hey we gotta stop the interview to tell
you about our partners at Odd Socks baby
that's right shout out to our family at
Odd Socks man look the most comfortable
socks in the entire world
odd Sox official .com they just got the
Coca-Cola license they got the Scarface
license they got the WWE license they
got [__] Kool-Aid socks Chucky you
know what I'm saying Halloween's coming
get them [__] Chucky socks speaking
of Halloween what about the Ghostbuster
joints man oh these are gas they even
got the Ghostbuster underwear what I'm
trying to tell you is whatever you're
into they got them at Odd Socks
oddsoxofficial.com they just locked in
the brand new uh saving uh uh what's it
called
um
well look they got Transformers and
Power Rangers that's essentially what
I'm trying oh Hasbro the Hasbro license
all right they got all the socks draws
all that [__] plus they got the odd Sox
Basics which are my favorite just the
normal guys I mean I wear them every
single day of my life they're literally
the most comfortable socks and don't
forget about the underwear ladies and
gentlemen the underwear are there if you
want to get 20 off at checkout go to
oddsocksofficial.com use that promo code
bootleg 20 off at checkout odd
socksofficial.com
trust me all right you go with some of
these Odd Socks you put them on it ain't
the most comfortable socks you ever put
on your [__] life you know what
I'm saying DM me I'm not gonna reply but
they because you're a liar yeah I mean
anyway also I want to give a big shout
out to our family at King Palm baby
that's right shout out to King Palm man
listen I've been smoking these King
Palms since they've come on board and I
don't know what man look bro
these things right here
it's a tobacco-free leaf
just organic no no like uh no [__]
you know I'm saying just organic
I mean this thing right here this is
like it's natural what I like about it
you know what I'm saying now this is
what I like about King Palms is I went
from smoking just straight papers to
strictly King Palms and I love it
because I like the way they burn and I
like the way they taste because what
they do have are these terpene flavored
tips yes they're infused on the tip
tobacco-free you squeeze the tip
and it's a burst of flavor these are the
sugar punches shout out to Sugar Shawn
O'Malley uh these are the dragon fruits
what do we got here what do we got here
we got grape they got all kinds of
flavors I mean literally watermelon they
got an energy drink flavor California
cream whatever it is and check this out
right now not only can you go and get
King Palm at your favorite smoke shop by
your house maybe 7-Eleven pop in get you
some King Palm whatever smoke shop is
near you has King Palms liquor stores
all that but you can also go to the
website and get 50 off half off whatever
you want to order from King Palm they
got the smoking accessories the ashtrays
the Grinders I mean the glass tips
whatever you're into kingpom.com promo
code bootleg say 50 off at checkout
shout out to King Palm man I'm about to
smoke up right now after this podcast
all right yo let's get back to the
interview I just saw him recently and he
was smoking it it was like in public too
I was like oh he doesn't give a [__] but
I'm glad that you actually that was one
of the coolest people I've got however
they couldn't say it before but yeah
I've got a big who's the coolest person
you've got in Iowa this has got to be I
mean you probably got out with everybody
at this point
um somebody who sticks out you're like
wow I smoked with this person that's
[__] crazy dude dude to me it's still
be real dude
like I'm almost gonna be honest like be
real is a guy yeah and he gets he gets
really high and like when I see him it's
like a reunion of like here's the
flavors I've been [__] with here's
the flavors he's been [__] with we
just rolling back to back and
you know I just this childhood goal [__]
it's also like he's a legendary weed man
too you know these years so like my
favorite person you know I've gotten
high with this be real straight up yeah
be real uh obviously tell me how because
yo was this Snoop Wiz tour was this your
biggest tour you've done or one of them
at least it felt like one of the biggest
it felt good I think it was dope because
everyone was canceling their tours and
tour dates yeah no one wanted to mention
that the Snoop Dogg Wiz Khalifa Too
Short Warren G and Berner tour sold out
in every market like and in the in a
time where nobody was selling out shows
everybody was complaining everyone was
canceling and the coolest thing about
this tour for me was I got the opening a
slot right it was DJ oh shout out to DJ
Drama Drama was there yeah drama was
there he put on uh but like it was DJ
Drama than me and then it'd be worn too
short with Snoop
and when I first got offered this show I
was like [__] I got the opening so I'm
about to be [__] I'm like [__] yeah
because it was opening slots and those
Amphitheater shows can be they could be
interesting bro I've seen it 100
different ways too yeah I've seen it
yeah but the best thing about this show
was that it was never like that that
[__] was 85 full every time I went on
there's videos the whole tour I go into
7 P.M that [__] is full rocking nice
grown mature crowd getting there early
young and grown but they were there
early because they liked the lineup they
didn't want to miss it yeah they didn't
want to miss you they didn't want to
miss me they didn't want to miss Warren
G they want to miss too short they
wanted to see the whole show and so yeah
that that's where it was life-changing
for me I think Snoop so much for for
hand selecting that that lineup because
you did hand select that lineup and I
feel super grateful for that I got a
chance to bond with some of my you know
mentors and some of my the guys I grew
up listening to and looking up to got a
chance to chill with the Taylor gang you
know that's family
me and Stu got some deals coming out
that that tour there are pretty big we
got cookies by cookies coming soon under
his food umbrella so we're ready please
buy cookies yeah just snacks good snacks
I like that non-infused Walmart baby
yo for Snoop like I feel like have you
because because when we think of
weed and Hip-Hop we think I think it's
Snoop and I think it wins and I think
it'd be real then I think of you but in
terms of just like the general public
everyone thinks of Snoop Dogg right
you've done some weed stuff with Snoop
um for whatever reason it feels like
Snoop hasn't fully
uh cracked off in the space
in a way that you would expect him to I
know you guys have done stuff
um but have you have you like helped
Snoop out at all in that in that space
we launched we launched something
together that did hella well uh the
doggy bag it killed it I mean when we
dropped in in La the lines were down the
block we dropped in other markets people
loved it was a good genetic but I think
the thing with Snoop is that he's way
bigger than just focusing on a weed
brand he's he's an international [__]
icon no it's crazy this guy I'm I mean I
always tell this to people he's the most
famous rapper in the world I think he's
like he's one of the most famous people
he's like the closest like and I say
this this may be a weird statement he's
like the closest guy to Michael Jackson
out there like he's no one like Michael
everyone knows who's Snoop Dogg
everybody I don't care where you go
you're Grant like you know who the dog
is you know who the dog is so I think
that the dog I think that soup plus weed
he's a fan of weed he loves to smoke
good weed I've gotten high with him for
years he's got multiple Brands but I
think that he's just so much bigger than
trying to focus on the weed brain he's
focused on like the food category now
with the ice cream and the cereal like I
think he's focused on just like bigger
plays that he didn't really think he'd
be able to do you know when he was
younger Snoop and I think that line to
Walmart yeah [__] like that yeah I mean
he's not only getting into Walmart he's
opening the doors for other people like
he didn't have to open that door for me
that's why I bought him the Rolex at the
last day of the tour because I was like
you know I don't even know if he'll ever
wear this watch but like I'm so grateful
that
he opened up the door for me to help
normalize my myself as a household name
and by introducing that partner to
develop create cookies and to and to
actually distribute into places like
Walmart that's big as [__] for me and
I'm grateful for that and I think that I
told him that day I said you're the only
artist I know that gives back like this
yeah
you don't want nothing back he told me
burned up simple you could have brought
me a little bag we could say I know I
could have but like I want to give you
this from the heart because this is what
you know my world like this is I've
always dreamed about being able to do
something like this and like this tour
brought a lot of Happiness to my life in
a really dark time and this sure gave me
motivation to keep making music and it
showed me that around the country I'm
respected all in different markets I
never thought I would be and [__] bro
like you opening up big doors for us so
shout out to Snoop he's the only guy
that actually really shares his platform
and gives back and gives opportunities
to other artists when he ain't got to do
that [__] at all that's that's my role
model really no soup I I always see him
popping up on up and coming artist [__]
too like just like just randomly you'll
be like damn snoop's on like a zo Osama
remix or he's on a Scarlet record like
and it's just like oh he's he's not only
is he like
you know he just tapped in and I feel
like he's he's generous with his energy
man that dude ain't gotta do that dude's
Caked Up for sure Snoop Dogg is Caked Up
liquidly Caked Up in like his money's
not in equity one he's Caked Up For Real
for reals and he don't have to do
nothing she's doing he's doing because
he loves it and that's the dope thing
about the dog have any of the
like you know like when we think of a
guy like Diddy or we think of a guy like
hope have you had any discussions with
those guys at all about maybe just kind
of gaming them up in terms of the space
because it is a space that
you know like you said it helps to be
somebody who came from that life you
know what I mean someone who's a smoker
someone who cares about the culture of
cannabis you know what I mean I've sat
down with Diddy I've had like really
really cool like sit down with him and
had a good relationship with him
personally
dude's a [__] Legend bro he's an
iconic dude for sure I've actually had
the opportunity to talk with Jay-Z as
well
and you know it was a very it's like a
30 minute call but it was life goal [__]
yeah was that just about just what do
you think about just like cannabis and
like where cannabis is going and he gave
me a lot of game
um
you know we just were sharing your
thoughts about things and that's kind of
told them that you know like my goal
with this business is to leave it to my
daughter
but I would like to find a way to exit
one day and get some liquidity actually
get some real cash a couple hundred
million bucks that'd be cool yeah he
gave me some real game on how to do that
I'm grateful for that I gave him some
game
we talked about doing something you just
never really moved like that but like I
was on a [__] Zoom with Jay-Z it was
pretty cool it's crazy you know what I
mean like pretty [__] cool you know
talk to the whole salute to him
I'm grateful for the game you gave me I
hope that he found the game I gave him
valuable I'm here if they ever want to
chop it up again you know like game
Diddy some good game he gave me some
good game you know so I feel blessed
like it's one thing to be on that list
um I even sat down with Dr Dre about
weed before really yeah like face to
face yeah what was this face-to-face
dream eating like crazy because that's
really for someone who grew up in that
uh I told you I would give you gems on
this because I [__] with you you're very
consistent with like caring about my
story but like yeah shout out to slim
the mobster man
um he made a call back in the days yo
slim the mobster
[__] he was on aftermath he was in jail
and he made a call and from jail was on
the phone and you know I went and went
to go sit down with Drake I was like nah
man he ain't here man he ain't here that
was like shooting me away I was like man
slim I'm here bro
he ain't trying he said hold on
boom boom boom and not get let in I go
sit down and uh Andrea sat down with me
and I and I showed him a jar of what we
wanted to call The Chronic and it was by
far the best looking weed we've ever
produced
it was incredible beautiful it was
orange purple funky stanky just buzz
looked it was like it would look like it
was out of a [__] movie how good this
weed looked I showed him the chronic and
he was just like yeah
I [__] with it and I appreciate slim
putting this play together and you know
we'll think about it but like
I don't know if I really want to kind of
put myself in the industry and I I got
you know he told me I got money money
and I don't really want to play with
that until you know maybe it's federally
illegal I just don't want to risk it I'm
like what year was this this was like
like three or four years ago oh [__] so
not too far not too long ago yeah
um and I said I respect that and I said
can I leave this with you for yourself
or those who smoke he's like for sure
and I got like a nervous picture with
him uh Frederick took the picture for me
because he was air shot to Frederick
uh but yeah I think it's cool that like
being on that hip-hop list I think it's
cool because like Dre saw me he had to
see you and be like oh that's I remember
that guy yeah I remember that guy he
pitched me on this week because he's
doing pretty well yeah I guess it
[__] worked for him I think it's cool
because I got a chance to share moments
with Diddy and I got a chance to share
moments with Jay-Z and those are the top
four yeah and I didn't get I've never
met Kanye you know I don't know whatever
I have no opinion on that but I'm just
saying it's cool because I've ran into
all those guys and I felt good for them
to see me up there because I told them
what I wanted to do and what I was
building at the time and now they see
they have to see the list oh [__]
because the same guy that does their
evaluation and is kind of making sure
that you know they're they're their net
worth is credible and relevant is doing
mine so it's real you know I was gonna
say when that happens what is the uh
whether it's the four but or that list
what is like the influx in people just
in your DMs or bothering you or all of a
sudden trying to [__] with you it's got
to be crazy it's crazy bro
crazy I'm not the answer to anyone's
problems I promise you or just like I
would just see people like like posting
that would just never ever like post
about you or like even like acknowledge
your music or what you're doing and it's
like oh now you know now you know this
guy's on the cover of Forbes and now you
know you're [__]
I mean it's kind of cool you obviously
the more successful you get the more
people are going to come yeah they're
gonna they're gonna come they're gonna
come and like recognize game but like
again for me just it's life quotient
because I grew up looking up to Jay-Z I
grew up looking up to Diddy who didn't
right he grew up looking up to Dr Dre
Kanye's [__] no matter what anyone
says about the guy he's a [__] he's a
legend bro he's a he's a smart guy he
built he built out easy hard and so like
it's cool to sit next to us guys it's
cool to like be acknowledged by the same
guys that acknowledge Him on a wealth um
you know side of things but like [__] I
just felt good when I came out I was
like damn I just talked multiple of
these guys I told what I wanted to do I
think the coolest thing is bro I'm just
getting started yeah like we just I
can't say what but Vibes just locked
into something so big no The Vibes
papers are going crazy I feel like it's
I mean I feel like it's very hard to
take off the top dog and I feel like you
guys have done a really good job of like
like if I go to any smoke shop it used
to be if I went to a smoke shop and I
saw Vibes I thought oh you guys got
Vibes that's [__] sick you know bird
is my friend and that's cool it's
everywhere yeah but like the play we
just logged in for Vibes is so next
level bro like and you know you guys
will see it two years from now because I
probably won't be able to talk about it
for a while but like
it's one of those plays that like goes
down to history bro and so like I'm just
getting started so if I made that list
now right it's crazy because this alone
yeah
a beast of a business yeah Myers is
about a kit hard so like you know and I
feel like cookies is nowhere close to
where it's gonna be especially because
we haven't really added International as
much as we could possibly in the future
so
it's crazy because you've dealt with so
many uphill battles in every single one
of these spaces you're in like
especially like I remember when you you
had the public falling out with Josh and
Rod because if it feels like if I'm a
guy who has a company that depends on
weed users
and burner comes into that space I'm
freaking the [__] out because I know
it's gonna work yeah well especially
like if I come in that space I get next
to key players that actually make that
business what it's about to be because I
start getting next to everyone real
quick yeah real quick like
I didn't just say white label of a
rolling paper for me I went and found
the best rolling paper producer I went
and found the best specialty item
producer like the Cali the girl you
could have been lazy and did what and a
lot of people would have didn't just
white label some [__] yeah yeah we ain't
doing none of that and so the fact that
we started getting close to real people
I feel I think made other rolling paper
producers feel the threat but that
threat should have been felt till today
because the the document that came
through my email today is serious yeah
[__] better feel that threat
because I'm coming for the top space and
rolling paper business and I say that
with confidence with my balls hanging
down to my feet right now you know what
I mean where do you feel like um the
shroom games going because it feels like
at least on the black market it's the
new packs it's the new it's the new way
to get margins it's the new way to make
some [__] serious money it's
obviously a extremely illegal to Suicide
but in certain places like Oakland I
think San Francisco now legal or
decriminalized I know oh yeah they don't
give a [__] about that [__] I think
shrooms is about to be a big wave I
think it's going to be just like the
Cannabis it seems like the next thing
that's about to get poured out quickly
quickly
um you know there's obviously
um High medicinal purposes for it
especially therapeutic space 100 like
even without psilocybin mushrooms are
good for your body to go for your for
your for your minds because you have um
caps you have caps which is uh legal
mushrooms that you could go buy at any I
mean I'm assuming any cookies dispenser
Yeah we actually got like a some kind of
like um
some kind of like not a war but like
some kind of like some kind of
acknowledgment in men's health about
cash but I planted that seed real early
caps right because whenever psilocide
comes to be a thing you already have
caps I already have caps and you know
[__] it I'll tell you and whatever but
like we already have a bunch of
different like r d going on with like
real you know psilocybin style mushrooms
and like just finding the best you know
the best type of mushroom and you know
just kind of like doing our research on
a very small level in the background so
when that time comes we cheat just like
genetics like yeah it's nothing it's
nothing different because there's penis
envy there's tidal waves there's I mean
there's all different strains that do
different things that hit you
differently that'll give you different
emotional you know reactions and yeah
visibilities and so you know we're just
we're we're slow playing that we got the
legal side of mushrooms already on deck
and they're really good for your sleep
and really good for your daytime you
know I love them man yeah they're good
for you know for like the mind and being
a sharp and when you know recreational
hits for suicide and weren't positioned
to introduce it and be ready and in a
very good way with like purpose and like
with good quality product but I think
that psilocybin would just be just like
the canvas industry all these chats are
going to come in try to [__] it up I
think that's actually
happening right now because I I saw I
just watched a YouTube video
um that someone's trying to trademark or
copyright like psilocybin therapy which
is a weird thing to try to like it's
it's some weirdo [__] going on already
in that space yeah [__] all that [__]
I'm crazy like in your position right
being in so many different cities so
many different markets do you ever have
to deal with like any because you know I
know right now there are lobbyists that
are trying to get suicide and [__] pass
through but do you ever have to deal
with like politicians or anybody who's
like because that's it feels like it
feels like there's definitely got to be
a agenda or a Lobby on both sides to
make it federally legal and or illegal
and it feels like you might have some
sort of insight on whatever like on like
in certain markets like when they're
holding back our license to open in a
store I'll talk to like certain uh
politicians and kind of just say hey
like what's going on like we'd love to
build you know whooping a good chance to
say hello but I I mean bro if I'm ever
invited the White House or if I'm ever
invited somewhere around some of these
lawmakers I would love to give my input
I was gonna say do you think federally
it's gonna happen soon in terms of no no
five years ten years I feel like I don't
know why one of these [__]
[__] running for president
doesn't just [__] say guys I'm gonna
make weed leaves because there's too
many old people in position presidents
are just puppets it's just [__] crazy
yeah you would think like you you
probably win the election just run that
you're making weed legal and you're
gonna free [__] marijuana prisoners
that's crazy they don't want to do that
there's too much money behind keeping
people locked up and there's so many old
people with old thoughts and old agendas
in position we need some of these guys
to kind of phase out and let the new
generation take office I give it 10
years I think 10 years I would love to
be optimistic and say could we can go
legal soon so I can really build my
business the way it should be built and
we can give her these weird ass laws
like 280 and [__] but I don't see it
happening anytime soon that's why I
spread my wings really hard and stay
relevant many other ways
um give me your top five rappers ever
Park
uh
Bone Thugs is a group
yeah crazy bomb right now
um
definitely
[__] this is tough I'm biased man I'm
[__] I'm old school dog I mean Snoop
you got Park bones Snoop
um
I mean biggies in there for sure
and
[__] dude this is tough
I'm so old school man I'm so old school
when it comes to music uh
[__] I'm gonna get ridiculed for this
list
um
fifth person bro DMX [__] it DMX and you
got to work with DMX yeah before you
pass which is crazy I related to his
[__] a lot now there's a bunch of people
I should have said politically or
whatever but that's just what comes to
my head right now what I'm listening to
right now I'm surprised you didn't do
the political Bay Area record of
throwing there well that's his own list
you know that's his own what's the Bay
Area list
[__]
um you know the Jacka
um the Jack uh
Mac Dre for sure E40 San Quinn
and I mean bro you got to give two
shortest Too Short yeah yeah
it's crazy I feel like people who aren't
from the Bay
will never quite uh
understand Mac Dre like Ora San Quinn or
even the jacket for sure the Jagger
that's my number one Bay Area you know
I'm one of his biggest fans but the San
Quinn's probably one of the best rappers
out this at the bay I think out the West
Coast you just never got a chance to
shine like that on a very very major
level but like Quinn still got heat to
this day yeah yeah for sure no I think
it's crazy because I had I had that talk
with a
somebody else from debate I won't
mention but we're we're kind of talking
about how like like I
understand why Mac Dre is important I
understand
you know I I also understand from what a
lot of people told me about
people didn't really in terms of the
streets [__] with him and like like at
least his thizz air [__] until he passed
it was more like some Berkeley [__] and
then once he passed people kind of
really truly appreciate it gravitated to
him yeah he did you know what I'm saying
um all right man well [__] hey before we
go can you give me the last time we hung
out you gave me
um
OG uh burner in the in the uh
I forget what happened you almost you
afraid you were gonna get robbed in the
mountains of Humble County yeah that
[__] went super viral let's let's dive
back 15 years 20 years burn give me the
another random
just Story Time with Burner give me a
crazy story about a a situation that
might have been dicey back in the day
um it could have been in Humboldt County
it could have been in the Streets of San
Francisco give me give me a little
anecdotal little tidbit man before we go
well
I guess a good one would be um
unless I want to handle something for me
one time and uh you know I just I felt
in my gut that wouldn't be the right
move I said bro like be a very attentive
these guys are kind of like
these guys are kind of Shifty and I
don't think they're gonna Rob You by
gunpoint but I feel like something's
gonna go wrong so you know I'm gonna let
you handle this because I'm not around
but like be very attentive to what
happened she's like for sure I got you
so he goes to meet up with this guy in
the hotel and
he gives them the bags in a duffel bag
and the guy gives them the money the
money is vacuum sealed and um you know
it looks right hundreds on top or
whatever and there was two vacuum seal
bags
and kind of made a joke like what you
don't trust me you want to counter here
you really want to count it all here I
got [__] to do I got to move I gotta go
box these up and get them out of here
and just like yeah you know he's like
bro at least bust open one you can count
it real quick and dude opened up for him
the vacuum sealed back and hand them a
stack and count it through a whole stack
it's all Honeys boom boom boom cool put
it back in he's like bro I gotta go I
gotta move you know I mean
boom my boy takes off can see where he's
going opens up the vacuum seals and the
rest of all the stacks are just 100 on
top of all ones oh and I'm like he calls
me and tells me like bro you really let
this man pull out the attacking counter
for you like I mean he didn't count it
for him but you really let him open that
pack up and he knew it was probably like
you let him give you the right corner
stack he didn't go through anything else
he's like bro he's moving so fast it was
nervous it was just seem Shady he was
opening up the packs to start smiling
the room I just want to get out of there
with all that bread and I was worried
about getting robbed when I left on my
foot you're worried about getting robbed
when you left but you got robbed right
there he's calling to do his phones for
Deuce phone job services how much how
much money are we talking
I don't even remember at the time it was
like probably like 16 years ago or
something like that but I just know my
boy got [__] big time and it fell on
him I'm like bro you were there to
handle it you were there to count the
bread I told you what to do you didn't
do it so that's all you gotta eat that
[__] out yeah and he never paid me
back for it but yeah that was a random
one so and for all them bad boys out
there if someone comes with a neatly
stack of hundreds all flattened out
perfect in the vacuum so go through it
yeah you should never just take the
vacuum seal of money just open it up
make sure it's there it's actually I
mean you're already somewhere doing a
deal it's I mean you already invested in
this situation counted out so you know
that's just a good old story that
happened someone pulled a slick one of
my little homie and other homie is
supposed to pay me back but he did not
the crazy [__] is
in downtown L.A
it's it's the Wild Wild West like if
you're downtown and you live in a
high-rise I guarantee you there is a
Trapper on your floor and if you see
guys moving around with tons of luggage
all the time they're not traveling
downtown LA is wild right now rappers
stop shouting out these these trap guys
man let them like let them build an
organic following themselves this is
crazy [__] snitching dude dog it's
like yeah it's crazy man
um well look man obviously uh people can
go I mean you got one's a New Mexico
opening Albuquerque November 3rd so
November 3rd that's coming new music
coming collab project with be real on
the way Mozzy uh oh Jeezy Mojo cookies
clothing is going crazier than ever yeah
I feel like you guys probably I mean
keeping Zoomies alive at this point
Julie's has been a great party for us
man you guys are [__] front and
center yeah yeah they've been a great
party we got two uh shoes coming out
next year with somebody I'm not gonna
say tennis shoes yeah like sneakers are
they fly yeah
hmm
okay
I'll keep coming with that you know I
keep coming with it man it's gonna be a
cookie sneaker coming yeah they try to
write me out man it's not happening I
love the slides yeah slides are good but
I'm talking about like a partnership
with a bigger company
like a collab sneaker a collab sneaker
yeah it's not just us putting out no
it's a collab with a pretty big brand
relevant brand and so why do you guys
stop doing denim or is it you guys not
do it as much because you're a big Jean
guy yeah I mean I don't know that's just
tough focus on what you do business yeah
yeah focus on what works man well look
uh cookie shoes on the way so much going
on
um
oh real quick uh I know you're a big
Maui guy I had to be tough to see what
happened in Maui that's when I go to
Maui I stay like that's where I'm at I'm
always in in Lahaina eating food and you
know I go to that big ass tree and eat
dough like so it's uh it's a terrible
situation shout out to everyone on the
ground putting in that work out there in
Maui a lot of people are making sure
that they're taken care of I know that's
kind of like your like dream like if I
retire you always talk about like going
to Maui yeah I mean I definitely want to
be in the Maui or Kauai but like yeah
shout out to everyone in Maui I've
checked in I've helped out you know I'm
not gonna I'm not one of those guys that
publicly just posts what I do for things
but you know I've helped out in the ways
I can and I know that there's good
people on the ground making sure people
are good out there for sure man well
there it is Big Burn I appreciate you
brother appreciate you bro yes sir yes
sir boom hey what up man uh you just
watched another episode of the bootleg
cat podcast brought to you by hard Dean
baby shout out to the family at hardean
don't forget
make sure if you're in Las Vegas you get
into that taxi as soon as you land you
get into that Uber say take me to
hardine all right they're gonna take get
you taken care of the most craziest
Premium Selection of cannabis you'll
ever find Under One Roof it's a vibe in
there the bud tenders they're gonna take
care of you man listen tell them I sent
you they're gonna get you right shout
out to the family at Hardin in Las Vegas
the number one dispensary in the world
all right and we are so proud to be
partners with them so shout out to
hardine go follow them online Harding
underscore Las Vegas and check out their
website hardinglasvegas.com get you some
swag you know you can't buy this but you
know yeah shout out to hardine